[Musique]
elle est une bruxelles vient d'autoriser
le vaccin d'astrazeneca le troisième
après ceux de pfizer bien tu es moderna
une annonce d'ursula von der leyen la
présidente de la commission de l'union
européenne après que l'agent ce
justement européenne des médicaments a
profession d'utilisation pour le plus de
18 ans l'europe sous pression face aux
retards de livraison des vaccins déjà
commandé chiens et c'est le cas aussi
pour la france dans ce contexte comment
faire face à la pandémie de colis 19
essais paris un conseil de défense
sanitaire se tient depuis 18 heures à
l'elysée avec une question quel type de
confinement choisir pour ne pas
angoisser un peu plus les français
emmanuel macron doit se prononcer
dimanche ou tout autre au début de la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]
le chef de l'état qui devrait effectuer
une troisième visite au liban selon la
chaîne al arabia là-bas la contestation
contre la gestion de la pandémie ne
faiblit pas en ligne de mire la
l'éthique on s'attend encore ce soir à
les tensions notamment dans la capitale
tripoli pour une cinquième journée
consécutive un bilan des violences
depuis plusieurs jours un morts et 400
blessés
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france face à aux
retards de livraison dans toute l'europe
bruxelles accélère le rythme à la
présidente de la commission européenne
or sur la vente d'art leyen vient de
l'annoncer l'union européenne autorise
le vaccin d'astrazeneca hosford l'
agence européenne des médicaments a
approuvé aujourd'hui son utilisation
c'est le troisième après ceux de pfizer
biotech et moderna le laboratoire
britannique a salué le feu vert européen
et promet un accès large et équitable
par ailleurs le régulateur européen
prévoit bientôt une demande
d'autorisation d'un autre vaccin johnson
and johnson
sachez encore que l'union européenne a
publié le contrat passé avec astrazeneca
de son côté l'allemagne émet des
réserves et des conseils même le vaccin
aux personnes de plus de 65 ans nous ne
comptons pas sur une approbation sans
restriction le débat de ces derniers
jours et que nous n'avons pas
suffisamment de données sur les
personnes âgées pour le faire soit dit
en passant la question est plutôt de
savoir si les données sont suffisantes
ou non il est important à mon avis de
communiqué qu'un vaccin approuvé est
également efficace pour le groupe pour
lequel il est approuvé et recommandée
est de son côté la russie poursuivre sa
lutte contre le coc u19 avec son accent
spoutnik v la courbe des contaminations
laisse présager un espoir ont fait le
point à moscou avec notre correspondante
verhaeghe hoffman 19200 38 nouveaux cas
du coc vides ont été détectés en russie
ce vendredi
la courbe des contaminations continue sa
descente partout dans le pays
moscou épicentre de l'épidémie en russie
enregistre également une baisse avec
seulement 2799 nouveaux malades au lieu
de trois ou quatre mille les semaines
précédentes
la directrice de l'agencé sanitaire
russes rospotrebnadzor anneaux popova y
voir un présage de la victoire dans la
lutte contre la pandémie
il y as certainement un espoir que le
régime qui rend le port du masque
obligatoire soit levé cette année et cet
espoir repose d'une part sur le fait que
nous avons déjà démontré qu'une
avions appris à vivre avec ce virus et
d'autre part la vaccination est en cours
pour que nous puissions contrôler cette
maladie
au moins 60 % du nombre total d'adultes
doivent être vaccinés en russie à
l'exception de ceux qui ont déjà eu
cette maladie
aujourd'hui 20 à 25 % moyenne ont déjà
développé des anticorps d'autres ce
virus mais il faut vacciner tous ceux
qui pour le moment n'ont pas encore été
malade fut guérie et les ballons outre
la russie le vaccin russe foot nick v
est utilisé à l'étranger l'algérie
reçoit ce vendredi sa première livraison
des cinq cent mille doses prévues du
remède russe la vaccination il débutera
le 30 janvier par les médecins et les
personnes âgées
la bolivie a également reçu son premier
cargo de vingt mille doses du vaccin
russe ce vendredi c'est le deuxième pays
de l'amérique latine
après l'argentine a acheté spoutnik v
buenos aires en est à sa troisième
livraison d'une somme de 220 mille doses
les deux précédentes en ayant compté 300
milles chacune
le vaccin russe sollicité par la bolivie
un premier lot de spoutnik veille
d'ailleurs arrivés dans le pays plus de
dix mille personnes ont succombé là-bas
au virus le président bolivien luis arce
était présent sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport pour accueillir les 20000
première dose du spoutnik v on écoute
aujourd'hui les boliviens peuvent
respirer tranquillement ils peuvent
commencer lentement et progressivement
reprendre une vie normale
car malheureusement si cela avait été
fait l'année dernière nous serions
maintenant dans une meilleure situation
et le vaccin chinois sinopharm approuvé
par la hongrie le régulateur hongrois a
donné son feu vert à l'utilisation du
vaccin alors que les autorités
sanitaires européennes ne l'ont pas
encore fait par ailleurs budapest a
également approuvé le vaccin chinois
sinopharm en chine justement une équipe
d'experts de l'om s est rendu
aujourd'hui dans un hôpital de lujan ses
membres ont passé deux semaines en
quarantaine ils se sont rendus dans la
journée dans un hôpital de de la ville
c'est là que certains des premiers 4
coronavirus ont été traités les
investigations vont durer 15 jours sous
pression l'elysée a convoqué un nouveau
conseil de défense sanitaire à 18h le
signe peut-être que les nouvelles
mesures sanitaires contre le coc vide 19
et ces variants pourrait être annoncée
dès ce week end ou lundi par le
président emmanuel macron d'ailleurs on
a appris juste à l'instant
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
devrait donc s'exprimer pour donner jean
castex le premier ministre parle on
devrait s'exprimer pour annoncer de
nouvelles mesures
depuis l'elysée on va attendre donc
les interventions d'intervention en tout
cas on risque de le confiner reste à
savoir sous quelle forme elle les
autorités jour sur la sémantique on a
d'abord évoqué mis sous cloche serre est
maintenant adapté
le chef de l'état attend les résultats
définitifs de deux études sur la
présence des variantes pour prendre sa
décision c'est ce qu'il avait dit on
devrait connaître les résultats
préliminaires d'une deuxième enquête en
début de semaine prochaine selon santé
publique france 6 3e confinement il ya
il pourrait être débattue et votée au
parlement écoutez à ce propos l'expert
en stratégie en communication politique
j casanova le président il a maintenant
une difficulté c'est que ce qu'ils
regardent en ligne de mire c'est dans 14
mois l'élection présidentielle on a
trouvé cette idée
parmi ces stratèges d'aller mettre en
première ligne
le parlement si le sénat se mettaient à
avoir un avis différent de l'assemblée
nationale eh bien on considère que les
français verraient bien que ce n'est pas
le président qui est responsable mais
les diverses instances parlementaires
qui n'arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord
et que c'est bien malheureux pour les
français mais que le président lui il a
fait tout ce qu'il pouvait je le disais
l'exécutif sous pression la france
confrontée à un retard de livraison des
vaccins conséquence plusieurs régions
ont dû reporter les rendez vous de la
première injection pour être certains
que les personnes ayant déjà reçu une
première dose puisse recevoir la
deuxième à temps cela concerne des
reports de rendez vous dans quatre
régions
mais olivier ferrand s'est voulu
rassurant la situation va rentrer dans
l'ordre a affirmé le ministre de la
santé en déplacement à l'hôpital
avicenne de bobigny en seine-saint-denis
on voit cela en détail avec catch up
éthiques nouveau rebondissement ou
plutôt nouveau creux de la vague dans la
campagne vaccinale les agences
régionales de santé d'ile-de-france des
hauts de france et de bourgogne franche
comté vont connaître une pénurie de
vaccins
elles vont donc décalé des milliers de
rendez-vous pris pour une première
injection et ce afin de garantir des
douze de rappel pour les patients déjà
engagés dans le processus
on écoute olivier ferrand le ministre de
la santé et de l'éducation il ya pu
avoir des ce qu'on appelle des primo
injection qui peuvent être reporté de
quelques jours pour plusieurs raisons
effectivement il ya des diminutions de
l'arrivage de vaccins par rapport à ce
qui nous avait été promis tout cela va
s'arrêter
ça rentre dans l'ordre mais bien sûr
rassurez vous car pour une fois nous ne
sommes pas l'exception française nos
amis allemands pour ne citer qu'eux
connaissent également des ruptures
d'approvisionnement qui dureront jusqu'à
fin avril
c'est dommage car jusqu'ici
contrairement au coin du début la
campagne de vaccination française avait
fini par tenir ses promesses
le gouvernement avait prédit qu'un
million de français seraient vaccinés à
la fin janvier et le résultat avait
dépassé les espérances puisque hier on
comptait un million 349 me vacciner avec
1000 centres de vaccination de proximité
pas mal pour ce voyez presque en
terrasse avec un café mais pas de chance
décidément mais dieu ne sont pas avec
olivier ferrand
cette nouvelle pénurie est due à une
casquette de retard à tous les étages
qui les producteurs de vaccins
la campagne reposer en grande partie sur
le vaccin de pfizer qui accuse un retard
temporaire de livraison pour deux cent
mille doses alors on a imaginé que le
vaccin américain jordan dont on a
commencé à recevoir les deux allaient
compenser ce retard
puisque le laboratoire est à la peine et
ne livrera que 75 % des 2 attendus en
février soit 150 milles de moi mais nos
espoirs reposent et aussi sur le vaccin
anglo-suédois ans celui d'astrazeneca
pachès le laboratoire ne va pas respecté
son engagement à livrer aux 27 états
membres de l'union européenne
il ne fournira qu'un quart de la
production prévue d'ici fin mars soit
4,5 millions de doses au lieu de 17
millions les retard serait dû à un
problème survenu dans leur usine belge
400 yens allons nous fournir dans leurs
usines britanniques
eh bien non nos anciens partenaires du
royaume uni ne sont plus nos amis ils ne
veulent pas partager les vaccins le pdg
français d'astrazeneca
pascal soriot s'est montré très détendu
ce n'est pas un engagement contractuel
on dit on fera de notre mieux
sans garantie de réussir at il argumenté
avec une telle motivation
ce serait donc un miracle que les deux
arrivent ursula von der leyen la
présidente de la commission européenne a
eu beau taper du poing sur la table
les pressions de l'union n'ont rien
changé alors elle a décidé de rendre
public le contrat ce vendredi pour
obliger astrazeneca assurer ses
livraisons
que penser de cet enlisement des
réponses du professeur bruno mais garda
chef du service de réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris
dans notre hôpital depuis depuis
maintenant une semaine
plus aucune nouvelle vaccination n'a
lieu
le but est désormais de privilégier
l'administration de la seconde dose à
mon sens ce qui est important c'est de
vacciner plus de 80% des voire 100 % des
personnes âgées et des personnes à
risque il sera toujours temps de
vacciner les personnes plus jeunes voire
les enfants pendant l'été
selon le ministère de la santé la france
ne recevra que 4,6 millions de doses
d'ici mars soit deux fois moins que
prévu
et encore si tout va bien l'objectif de
quatre millions de vaccinés d'ici fin
février sans irréalisable il faudrait
plutôt tabler sur deux millions cinq
cent mille et avec cette nouvelle
déconfiture
vous le sentez venir le confinement et
le gouvernement qui promet plus de deux
milliards d'euros supplémentaires pour
les quartiers prioritaires
jean castex était en visite ce matin à
grigny dans l'essonne pour aborder la
politique de la ville et répondre aux
inquiétudes des acteurs locaux dans le
contexte de crise actuel et comme prévu
le chef du gouvernement a annoncé des
fonds supplémentaires pour la rénovation
urbaine l'éducation ou encore la
sécurité et écoutez à ce propos benjamin
morel et les docteurs en sciences
politiques mais sur des litiges qui sont
des politiques d extrêmement longue
haleine pendant très très longtemps ce
que l'on a à pied au renouvellement d'un
an plis ké essentiellement de revoir la
politique d'urbanisme et d'envisager la
mise en place d'une structure qui est
des structures assez isolé du quartier
avec pour objectif à travers un certain
nombre d'activités renouveler de
dynamiser un tissu et comment de kilamba
aujourd'hui sa relativement aux
fonctionner et qu'il faut passer à une
vidange des titres dynamisation travers
l'installation de services publics et à
travers la capacité à développer de
manière endogène des activités
illustration des conséquences
économiques et sociales de la crise
sanitaire se dirige-t-on vers la fin de
carambar c'est en tout cas ce que
pensent les salariés de l'usiné
historique de marcq en baroeul situé
dans le nord de la france ce site qui
produit les célèbres bars caramélisées
depuis 1954 doit être relocalisés ce qui
pourrait entraîner à des pertes
d'emplois on voit seul avec renault
parquet et cyrielle bourriche
le ton monte entre les salariés et la
direction de carambar depuis plusieurs
semaines une grève a été lancé et
l'entreprise tourne au ralenti en cause
la délocalisation de cette usine
historique construite en 1899
sur le site de lüthi à quelques
kilomètres de là dans la ville de
bondues pour les habitants de la commune
de marcq en baroeul
difficile d'imaginer une journée sans
odeur de caramel pourtant cette décision
prise en novembre dernier n'est pas le
vrai problème des salariés alors que le
site comprend 114 salariés seuls 105
postes seront reconduits à bondues 6 9
salariés sont donc dans le flou quant à
leur avenir dans l'entreprise pour ce
qui reste c'est la douche froide
la direction a annoncé une baisse de
salaire pouvant aller jusqu'à -25 %
selon les syndicats une honte
selon andré joris salariés de l'usiné et
secrétaire du ce et est ce on se sert
d'une crise économique pour pour faire
un peu n'importe courant les patrons
sont un peu en roue libre en ce moment
il profite de cet état de fait et on en
paye les pots cassés
il s'était engagé sur certains points
ils sont revenus en arrière hier ils ont
eu nous ont même enlevé des choses
qu'ils étaient sur plan social c'est un
plan social qui ne ne délivre pas
d'argent actuellement à l'heure actuelle
il ne livre rien c'est une honte c'est
un scandale
on est en train de bâcher les salariés
donc c'est les gens ils n'en peuvent
plus ici honnêtement 1
si notre si notre direction du synode
pdg s'obstine comme sahin continue à
s'obstiner comme ça pas écouter les
salariés
j'ai peur qu'au bout d'un moment où l'on
peut voir disparaître le carambar une
disparition de la célèbre barre
caramélisées catastrophique pour cette
entreprise seuls au monde à fabriquer
cette confiserie
chaque année ce sont sept mille cinq
cents tonnes de caramel qui sortent de
l'usiné de marcq en baroeul
du côté des salariés plusieurs
propositions ont été faites selon andré
joris notamment une indemnité pour
compenser la perte des salaires bruts
des propositions rejetées par la
direction présents sur le site ce
vendredi adrien catena ce député la
france insoumise de la première
circonscription du nord a tenu à
soutenir ses salariés
on observe c'est que la situation de la
pandémie va détruire des emplois de
manière assez considérable l'eau fce
estime que d'ici à fin 2021 ça pourrait
être quelques 800 mille emplois qui vont
disparaître
et dans le même temps on voit qu'à deux
choses il ya les entreprises qui
pâtissent vraiment de la crise et il ya
celles qui profitent de la situation
aussi il faut le dire est souvent
d'ailleurs des entreprises qui ont
bénéficié des aides publiques de l'état
il faut le rappeler
donc on pourrait imaginer par exemple
puisque notre président de la république
a dit qu'on était en temps de guerre en
2020 en france lé milliardaire français
en pleine pandémie ont engrangé 175
milliards de plus ces deux fois le
budget annuel de l'hôpital public
ne peut-on pas imaginer une contribution
exceptionnelle dans la période de
pandémie qui pourrait venir notamment au
renfort des entreprises en difficulté et
au premier chef des salariés en grève
depuis le 10 décembre dernier les
salariés de cette usine ne décolère pas
et souhaitent comprendre la raison de
cette baisse de salaire pour un poste
équivalent pour obtenir des réponses nos
équipes ont tenté de joindre la
direction en vain à ce jour un vent de
gronde général se fait sentir face aux
restrictions sanitaires de plus en plus
difficile à supporter on voit des
manifestations en europe notamment
on fait le point en images avec clément
var des chiens ce jeudi l'organisation
mondiale de la santé a indiqué qu'il
était trop tôt pour lâcher du lest sur
les restrictions en europe
aux pays-bas des émeutes ont eu lieu
dans plusieurs villes ces derniers jours
les manifestants s'opposent à
l'instauration du couvre-feu
une première depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale en espagne plusieurs milliers
de personnes ont défilé dans la capitale
pour protester contre les mesures
imposées par le gouvernement afin de
contrer l'épidémie les autorités ont
notamment décidé de restreindre les
déplacements entre les régions en italie
les restaurateurs sont descendus dans la
rue pour crier leur mécontentement
certains ont même décidé d'ouvrir
clandestinement depuis le 14 janvier un
décret à deux vitesses autorise les
établissements situés en zone jaune à
ouvrir tandis que ceux situés dans les
régions classées en zone orange ne
peuvent servir les clients sur place
dans la capitale autrichienne des
milliers de personnes ont défilé la
plupart sans masque pour protester
contre les conséquences économiques de
la pandémie sur les banderoles certains
réclament le départ du chef du
gouvernement
le chancelier sebastian course en
bulgarie des centaines de restaurateurs
et patrons de discothèques ont défilé
dans plusieurs villes contre la
fermeture de leur établissement
il estime que la moyenne actuelle de 500
cas par jour dans le pays est suffisante
pour alléger les restrictions au liban
on redoute une cinquième nuit de
contestation ira à tripoli de nouveaux
heurts la mairie de la ville a été
incendié et les manifestants s'en sont
pris aux domiciles de politique
le bilan des manifestations depuis
plusieurs jours contre les restrictions
sanitaires un mort et au moins 400
blessés
elle est libanais a déjà gravement
touchée par une crise économique sans
précédent va écouter à georges cette
année les fêtards général de la croix
rouge libanaise
c'est très grave
compte tenu de la situation du fait
qu'ils doivent respecter ces protocoles
ses règles et ses règlements
ces gens-là souffre entre leurs besoins
et la pauvreté
ils demandent de l'aide et veulent
montrer comment ils peuvent subvenir à
leurs besoins et nourrir leurs familles
aujourd'hui les hôpitaux sont pleins et
presque l'ensemble de leurs capacités 90
% sont utilisés pour lutter contre le
coc vide 19 et on doit faire face à de
nombreux problèmes pour que les malades
parviennent aux urgences en tant que
croix rouge
nous sommes prêts à être sur le terrain
et a aidé les deux camps parce que comme
vous le savez hier il ya eu des blessés
de part et d'autre parmi les forces de
sécurité intérieure et pour le plus
grand nombre parmi la communauté la
colombie maintenant face à une crise
migratoire un millier
migrants bloqués près de la frontière
avec le panama de plus c'est le deuxième
pays d'amérique latine le plus touché
par la coved 19 après le brésil on voit
tout cela avec un chardy de maurice
détente comme simple abri de fortune
ils sont plusieurs centaines de migrants
bloqués vers les colis une petite ville
située dans le nord de la colombie
les autorités locales estiment que leur
présence entraîne un risque sanitaire
pour les habitants du fait de l'épidémie
de coronavirus et réclame un corridor
humanitaire à la frontière actuellement
fermée avec le panama en majorité
haïtien et cubains ce millier de
personnes rêvent de rejoindre à tout
prix les états unis grâce à
l'intermédiaire de passeurs ce que nous
voulons c'est que s'il vous plaît
quelque part je ne sais pas une autorité
compétente écoute notre demande et
qu'elle facilite la vente de billets
afin que nous puissions traverser et
continuer notre odyssée la même
autorités colombiennes et le maire nous
disent pratiquement que nous devons
louer un bateau clandestin pour 400
dollars je ne veux pas faire ça avec mon
fils nous n'avons pas d'argent nous
travaillons pas ici nous vivons avec nos
économies des économies avec lesquels
nous devons faire le voyage
nous les dépenses ont encore et
maintenant nous n'avons plus rien le
golf du rabat est l'un des principaux
points de passage des migrants dont
certains viennent aussi parfois d'asie
pour rejoindre l'amérique du nord par la
mer des caraïbes
sept migrants sont morts noyés au début
de l'année lors du naufrage d'une
embarcation illégales dans la région
les migrants demande l'ouverture de la
frontière pour poursuivre leur voyage
mais ce n'est pas le moment de se
mobiliser au contraire c'est le moment
de se mettre à l'abri afin de minimiser
les risques de contagion du coc vie de
10,9
la colombie a décrété la fermeture de
ses frontières terrestres et fluviales
le 16 mars 2020 une mesure prolongée
jusqu'au 1er mars prochain pour enrayer
la propagation du coronavirus
l'actualité marquée en inde par une
explosion devant l'ambassade israélienne
située dans la capitale new delhi
cet après midi trois voitures ont été
endommagées d'après la police sans faire
de blessé le quartier de l'ambassade a
été bouclée après la déflagration causée
par un engin de très faible intensité
selon les autorités on reste en inde où
les tensions à new delhi justement sont
fortes en cause la colère des
agriculteurs qui demandent la suspension
d'une réforme agraire
une mobilisation qui dure maintenant
depuis plus de huit semaines
elle donne lieu à des affrontements avec
les forces de l'ordre les détails c'est
avec médias ce qu'affiche des
négociations totalement rompu et des
heures dans la rue entre paysans et
autorités les esprits s'échauffent de
plus en plus lors de manifestations
cette semaine partisans et opposants au
mouvement des agriculteurs se sont
violemment affrontés déclenchée en
novembre dernier la colère paysanne
contre la réforme agraire n'est toujours
pas retombée
les agriculteurs se révoltent contre une
série de lois qui visent à libéraliser
la vente de produits agricoles les
paysans indiens se disent condamné
lorsque nous n'avons plus de terre
lorsque nous pouvons plus cultivé nous
allons mourir de toute façon au moins si
nous mourrons ici en protestant nous
aurons des martyrs nous allons nous
battre et mourir pour les droits des
habitants de ce pays que le gouvernement
veuille faire s'il veut nous battre avec
ses bâtons ses matraques ou ses balles
nous ne l'arrêteront pas nous
continuerons à nous asseoir
pacifiquement dans les rues ils nous
sommes prêts à faire face à toutes les
mesures que le gouvernement veut prendre
plus de deux mois la tension est
palpable en inde et plus
particulièrement à new delhi des hommes
masqués se présente dans les
manifestations pour s'attaquer aux
agriculteurs qui protestent
après les débordements qui ont eu lieu
cette semaine le premier ministre indien
fortement critiqué ces derniers mois
s'est exprimé je suis confiant dans
l'espoir et les attentes du peuple
indien qui nous a envoyé au parlement
nous utiliserons le caractère sacré du
parlement en maintenant et en respectant
la dignité de la démocratie et pour la
réalisation des aspirations de son
peuple
nous ne tarderons pas à contribuer à la
même chose ce jeudi à new delhi les
syndicats d'agriculteurs ont renoncé à
une nouvelle marche après les violences
de mardi qui ont fait un mort et 400
blessés pour tenter d'anticiper de
nouveaux heurts
le gouvernement a mis en place
d'importants dispositifs policiers et
paramilitaires près des camps de paysans
et pour terminer on va parler des
bourses avec la sphère gamestop
elle soulève la question de la
manipulation des marchés financiers en
feu coordonnant pour acheter des titres
en ligne de traders amateurs sont
parvenus à faire flamber certaines
actions et à mettre en difficulté des
grands groupes d'investissement les
explications c'est avec estelle fâchent
une messe de la plateforme réédite une
communauté de boursicoteurs en ligne qui
compte tout de même plus de 5 millions
de membres
ces traders amateurs ont réussi à semer
un vent de panique à la bourse de new
york et à piéger en quelque sorte de
gros fonds d'investissement
ces derniers font ce que l'on appelle du
short sellings de la vente à découvert
en français grosso modo les short
sellers comme on les appelle achètent
des actions qu'ils espèrent voir n'ont
pas augmenté comme des investisseurs
classiques mais baissé il emprunte ainsi
des actions qu'ils ne possèdent pas les
vendent à prix fort en espérant pouvoir
les racheter une fois les prix
dégringoler et sam c'est ce que de gros
fonds d'investissement entend des rires
et avec gamestop une enseigne de jeux
vidéo en difficulté financière en mars
l'action gameloft ne valait que deux
dollars 57 les gros fonds
d'investissement ont donc porté l'action
c'est là que la communauté du forum
wall street baisse est entré en jeu en
se coordonnant en ligne ces amateurs se
sont rués sur l'action gamestop
provoquant une flambée considérable du
titre le 25 janvier dernier s'il peser
ainsi 347 dollars 51 à la clôture de
wall street
conséquence un vent de panique et le
début des difficultés pour les fonds
d'investissement exemple avec melvin
capitale selon le financiel times
l'entreprise new-yorkaise aurait ainsi
perdu entre 2 75 et 3 milliards de
dollars selon les estimations
face à la tournure des événements les
autorités publiques se sont emparés de
la faire le régulateur américain des
marchés financiers le s ici a indiqué
surveiller les faits de très près et la
classe politique à gauche notamment il
voit l'histoire de l'arroseur arrosé
pendant des années ces mêmes fonds
spéculatifs et investisseurs fortunés
consterné aujourd'hui par les
transactions sur gamestop ont traité le
marché boursier comme leur propre casino
alors que tout le monde en paye le prix
il est grand temps pour la sc les autres
régulateurs financiers de se réveiller
de faire leur travail et avec une
nouvelle administration et des
démocrates qui dirige le congrès j'ai
l'intention de m'assurer qu'ils le
feront
c'est vraiment quelque chose de voir des
gens de wall street qui ont longtemps
traité notre économie comme un casino se
plaindre d'un forum qui traite également
le marché comme un casino
nombreux sont ceux aussi à faire le
parallèle avec le mouvement de 2009
occupy wall street qui entendait faire
piller la finance dans un sens c'est dû
occuper wall street version 2.0 plutôt
que depuis le parc zuccotti après
gamestop les membres du forum wall
street baisse semble avoir d'autres
cibles ces derniers jours ils se
seraient déjà intéressés aux actions de
la chaîne de cinémas et m6 ou encore à
celle du fabricant de téléphones
blackberry une lettre ouverte a aussi
été adressée à l'âge
si nbc dans laquelle ses traders
amateurs déclare la guerre aux géants de
la finance
j'espère qu'ils vont souffrir nous
voulons voir des pertes en cascades
ont-ils ainsi écrit et pour rappel jean
castex va annoncer de nouvelles mesures
pour contrer l'épidémie du coït 19 une
annonce qui doit intervenir dans
quelques minutes à l'issue d'un conseil
de défense sanitaire qui s'est déroulé à
l'elysée à 18 heures toujours en cours
donc ce conseil de défense sanitaire
cette prise de parole depuis l'elysée
intervient alors que l'exécutif étudie
des nouvelles restrictions pour les pid
et contre l'épidémie avec un possible
reconfirme ans à la clé on attend donc
cette intervention de jean castex à
suivra en direct et on verra donc les
mesures annoncées et confinement ou pas
on le rappelle également en face aux
retards de livraison